こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さん
懐かしのお家
覚えてますでしょうか風強い皆さん懐かし
のお家覚えてますでしょうかここですね僕
がお世話になったはじめアミューズメント
パークハップ今3億円のうちに住んでるん
ですけどもそこに引っ越す前に僕が
とっても長い期間お世話になったお家久々
に見たでしょうもう実はですね最近ずっと
契約してて
借りてはいたんですけどももう使うことが
ないなと思いまして本当に最近
解約させていただきましたなので今ですね
ここ何も進んでないという状況になって
いるんですけれども
[音楽]
退去費皆さん気になってると思いませんか
対拒否あのー
普通には使ってなかったんですよさあ
昔の扉が外されてきました今まで扉さん
ありがとうございました
普通には使ってなかったどれぐらい住んで
たんだろう結構長い間住んでたんですけど
も
賃貸お家を借りると出る時に
退去費というものが発生するんですよ
いろいろあるんですけれども例えばどこか
こう
扉を壊していたりとか
床が傷ついていたりとか色々こうお部屋を
借りて生活していく上で傷ついちゃったり
壊してしまったりしたものを最終的に
退去費としてお金を払わなきゃいけないっ
ていうのがあるんですけれども俺気づいて
しまいましたそこそこ派手に使わせて
いただきましたこのお家
退去費どうなっているのかやばいですよ
やばい多分気になってると思いますあの
暴れん坊YouTuberが暴れん坊
YouTuberがちんたに住んでいたら
退去費がいくらになるのか今日はお見せし
たいと思いますまあ値段を聞く前ですね
ちょっと中どうなってるか最終確認してみ
ましょう
というわけでこのお家といえばこの方です
どうぞ
お久しぶりです
ね
本当にお世話になりました今ってこの部屋
ってどうなってるんですか
すごかったということで見てない
未聞です
ちょっと実際どうなってるかちょっと思い
ます
ありがとうございます
ね
全国の
投資とか
商売に興味のある方に行っておきますと
大家さんなんだけれども一括借り上げをし
てるんでほとんどタッチしてないです
何部屋アコード空室があろうと僕は一定の
収入を20年間
全く別の会社ということで僕どれくらい
住んでましたっけ結構
済ませていただいてましたよね34年な気
がしますねYouTuberが34年生も
どうなるのか見ていきましょうか4つの
まま上がっちゃっていいですか
ありがとうございますまずですね
喧嘩なんですけど
シンプルに
[音楽]
治った直ったね直りました直ったみたいだ
ね部分的に直してもらってるところは直っ
てるみたいです
扉も直ってますよこれとかもそうですよ
こういうの多分レゴとかかな
玄関周り全てレゴブロックで固めました
多分レゴとかで傷つけた後がこちらにあり
ます
そしてこれですよ皆さん
窓ガラスガードマンに割られました
僕じゃないです
ねクソみたいなYouTuberのガード
ワンってやつがいるんですけどそいつ
[音楽]
らにぶっ壊されてこれ割られてるんですよ
じゃあその分析しましょうはいここも全部
ガラス割れててめちゃくちゃになってたん
で安全のためにガムテープで貼って補強し
たっていうやつなんですけどもこれも
かなり大きな金額になってると思います
こんな感じで割れてますガードマンお前は
許されねえここがメインのお部屋って感じ
ですね
懐かしい
綺麗にはいこういう感じのお部屋でしたね
3回やります
汚れてるんだろうなぁガムテープの跡とか
ですかね割と耐えてる方ですけど床はもう
傷だらけになってますすみません
まあ懐かしい浴槽洗濯物途中からあんまり
しなかったから僕らは割と綺麗な状態です
大丈夫そうスライドのドアとかは結構
ボロボロになっちゃってるなぁ上に行き
ましょうか上に行こうと思います
よく寝てたからなぁ
そうだった
穴開けたんだったすいません
よく開けたよねいや本当に聞こえる
大台だよ
めちゃくちゃ硬いこれロケットつけてまし
たねここに
いやーこれとか相当高い気がするけどなぁ
まぁあとパッと見この部屋はそんなに
カーペットなのであんまり汚れることして
なかったので
傷は少ない方だと思いますベランダです
ベランダもね何回か撮影で使ったけど
ちょっと床が汚れてるとかかな何かを壊し
たりとかしてなかった気がします続いては
編集部屋として使ってたちょっと小さめの
お部屋ですね失礼しますここです
編集を捨てたお部屋になります
そんなに
編集だからめちゃくちゃ割れるとかはない
けど何このシミ
なんかやばい絶対なんか壊してるこれ
ぶっ壊れてるでも
でも初めて
表面だけだから
直しはいいんですよリアルに壁貫通とかだ
とちょっと話が変わってきてます
か
僕結構ハチャメチャ使ってたんですけど
本当にやばい時は一応大家さんに連絡はし
てました実は必ず相談がありました
YouTuberの人とかもし賃貸に住ん
でる人がいたらしっかり大家さんとか管理
人の人に連絡取るのがトラブル回避の
秘訣だと思いますだと思います気をつけて
ください続いては地下です行ってみ
ましょう俺の記憶だと地下で結構派手な
動画を撮った記憶があるんだよなぁ
やってここだなぁここ結構汚しちゃいまし
たね僕
頑丈だったでしょ
頑丈でしたこれとかも俺がやった記憶ある
んだよこれ何だっけなぁなんかこういう
コンクリートみたいなやつも俺の気がする
このシャッターの下のこの色の黄ばみは
象の歯磨き粉を確かここでパーンってやっ
たやつの記憶があります
だいたい地下はこんな感じですねどっちか
と床の
傷
汚れとかがかなり目立った気がします
やばい
はいというわけでまだいろんな部分に
壊れていたりとかなんか破損してたり知っ
てると思うんですけれども
ざっくりとこんな感じのお部屋でござい
ました親父の事柄ありがとうございました
ありがとう楽しませていただきました
ありがとうございますまだでも
隣の個室ですねはい一番初期から帰ってる
部屋はまだ足りているのでそちらではまだ
お世話になってます
ここが治りましたら私が半年か1年ぐらい
借りると思います
管理してる会社に私の名義って書いてる
いつでも遊びに来てください
気になる
このお部屋
退去費の方発表させていただきます私も
最強の平均ってどれぐらいなんですか
聞いたら高くても78万とか一般的なお
部屋だと一人暮らしとか多分
ひどくてなんか20万とか
なんですけれども
今回4000万来てください
YouTuberがすんだこの
賃貸の
退去費のお値段
200万円です
[音楽]
200万来ましたけども結構するなぁ押し
ますね
まあいろいろ含めて退去費高すぎな人は
思います
妥当なほどいろいろ使わせていただいて
ましたし普通の使い方してたら絶対壊れ
ないよ
それなりの覚悟を持ってして
大家さんに許可をいただいて
YouTuberがスムートなんと
修繕費退去費200万円行ってしまうと
いうことで今回分かりました
全国の大家さんYouTuberに優しく
対応しましょう僕からもお願いいたします